the Quran says the return of
Representative Scalise to Congress is a
unifying force
John Dickerson spoke with Ron yesterday
after Town Hall in Pennsylvania they
discussed how the experience in the
house chamber affected many members of
Congress today Steve Scalise came back
to the house what was that like I
haven't cried in a while
and I cried I mean I it was it was so it
was a beautiful moment for us
we've had so much bitterness in this
country we've had political acrimony we
went through a tough election we're
going through all these moments and
Steve Scalise was shot on a ball diamond
getting really practicing for charity
game and in Congress it made us look at
each other as fellow human beings who
are passionate about causes but who
respect one another and then a see Steve
go from literally nearly dying a few
times to relearning how to walk to
multiple surgeries to coming on the
House floor today it was a beautiful
thing it was so wonderful it helped it
gave us all a great feeling because so
many of us have been praying for Steven
his family but it also is unifying their
conversation touched on many pressing
issues including tax reform John
Dickerson is with us now John good
morning and we're internally is it
possible that somehow when there's so
much divide in Congress that this
outpouring of good faith and affection
could slip into politics
well you'd hope so it certainly did
yesterday in part because all these
members whether they're on the left of
the right know what it's like to have
this anger directed to them and so they
not only felt for a friend they not only
felt the joy of his return and touched
on the best feelings of sort of working
together but they also know that this is
a something that they all face in one
way or another and then they just had an
election in Alabama which put
Republicans against Republicans right
and you and you know a lot of the hot
rhetoric you get this moment showed us
you know the worst end of that and so
they all kind of think well we've got a
kind of settle back the problem is of
course politics takes over again and
people forget these moments
unfortunately so you were with Paul Ryan
at a pipe fitting manufacturing plant in
Pennsylvania so how is he selling this
tax plan to workers yeah well the way
he's trying to sell it is he's basically
saying this is a middle class tax cut so
he made his pitch and then one of the
first questions from the workers is wait
why is this money not gonna go to the
CEOs and as it gonna go to the
blue-collar people and his argument is
it's not just the reductions in the
actual taxes for middle-class workers
but he argues you lower the tax rates
for corporations they'll put that money
back into wages and investments now
that's a thing there will be a lot of
debate about because some people
say it won't necessarily go back to the
worker but that's the way he's making
his pitch what are the facts is this a
middle-class tax cut well it depends how
you do the math and the problem is you
can't do the math until you have the
numbers and the numbers aren't there
this is not a bill yet this is a
framework and part of the reason they're
pitching it as a framework is because
it's easier to sell a framework then
when you get down to the very numbers
but what Paul Ryan said when we talked
to him was he said the objective here
and it will fail if it is not when the
math is all done seen as the
middle-class tax cut but the challenge
for this of course is that the middle
class will get some relief but then
there will be people at the other end
who are gonna get big relief people who
get their money and/or have great big
investments in tax in in in the stock
market and those numbers and that
disparity will be what the political
conversation and attached to the debt
adds to the debt well it is a big
Republican issue in the past it does and
the argument will be well that growth
will that will be created by these tax
cuts will fix the debt problem and there
of course will be a violent debate about
that because that essentially assumes
that things are gonna turn out well and
and go move faster than growth has been
going and a lot of economists say that's
not possible in the economy at the
moment or even if growth gets going the
Fed will say wait a minute don't grow so
fast raise rates and that it will keep
these these this great revenue from
coming and where the Republican I mean
where the Democrats in all this well the
Democrats are saying no because they
think at this dis the you know the
central question here is whether the
system is tilted to those who've already
gotten the good stuff over the last many
years and whether because they have
lobbyists and accountants they can keep
the system tilted in their advantage and
Democrats will say that's what this bill
does and the challenge for Republicans
is to argue no we're trying to rebalance
to help the people who haven't been
helped in the last twenty years but
right now Democrats are not really even
part of the conversation we'll see if
the Republicans and the president let
them in thank you John
great to see charlie you can see John's
interview with House Speaker Paul Ryan
Sunday only on Face the Nation plus
Senate Minority Leader Chuck Schumer and
CBS News contributor Bob Schieffer
that's Sunday on CBS another big show
for John Dickerson thank you for taking
the time to join us this morning